Oh
Hello Welcome back to Outer Wilds Echoes of the Eye The Eye
Oh my goodness.
Time to get comfy and lurk in this lovely stream.
Hi, Mint.
Hello!
Parasocial.
Um, yeah, how else do ghosts?
Thanks.
Um, yeah.
Welcome back to Outer Wilds, Echo of the Eye.
Echoes of the Eye.
Not just a single echo, multiple echoes.
Um...
I'm a little scatterbrained because I had so much going on
today.
But I'm excited to continue this.
This is part two out of probably three.
I think today will be a little bit shorter of a stream
because I've talked a lot today, actually.
So even before this, my throat was feeling a little...
A little...
Uh, not hurdy.
A little sore.
So, will it be uploaded to YouTube?
The stream?
Uh, the stream?
Vocal cords a little strained?
Yes.
You could say a little strained, a little parasit-y.
Vocal parasites.
But, um, I'm thinking maybe like three hours.
Okay.
And then we'll finish it up next week in a part three.
YouTube content on YouTube?
Of course not.
Did you find the egg?
The egg.
You guys, the egg that...
Yesterday I thought I saw an egg.
The egg of the universe.
Might be four streams.
No, I think I'm going to endurance it next week.
I'm going to endurance it.
So, don't worry about it.
Um, the egg was an egg!
It was a real egg.
It existed.
It was on the screen.
It was a real egg.
It was an egg!
It's gonna be really endurance-y, though.
We'll see!
I looked it up!
Why did- Oh, my goodness.
My chair.
Why did I say that, though, DLC is like 10 hours, then?
Everyone's making it seem like it's a 50-hour DLC.
Echoes of the eyes.
Let's resume our expedition.
Depends on the person.
I'm smart!
Right!
Oh, let's wake up.
Oh, good morning.
So, I'm trying to think.
There was one place in particular from yesterday that I
really want to go to today.
It's the one location that I keep missing.
Hold on.
Oh, yeah, this is via the ship.
logs a little bit first as a um as a recap a recap um the
stranger we found the stranger it's an artificial ring world
hidden within some sort of cloaking field real mint words
not wikipedia copy pasted it is not herthian or no mine yeah
and we made a very long deals in Jeffrey that's okay it's
worth it's money's my money's worth right we went to the
radio tower to find it the red was it the reservoir oh look
at this an enormous reservoir with wooden piers and
buildings on both shores I found a room with a burned
control interface and a projection that seems to indicate a
broken connection between the stranger and another craft I
found a projection showing the stranger's current trajectory
and the sun's predicted supernova right it was moving away
from the sun
I saw a building marked with a unique symbol I think this is
the one that I wanted to go to recessed into one of the
canyon walls but the bridge that used to lead it lead to it
has rotted away oh I found several ornate metal artifacts
inside a workshop surrounded by ghost matter yes we went in
there we went in there okay but this cliffside building is
what is there's more to explore here in the reservoir.
Oh, well that's just like yeah, yeah.
What's...
Oh no, that's all the old stuff.
Okay.
But no egg to... There was an egg!
They just haven't said it yet.
Uh, map?
Where are you?
This isn't it.
Uh, hold on.
Uh.
view the log again there we go mark it on okay there we go
have fun playing it's my birthday today mr albusy happy
birthday happy birthday to you happy birthday to you happy
Why isn't it letting me autopilot?
Happy birthday, Mr. Albusy.
Happy birthday to you.
Oh, because I'm not locked on it.
Here I come.
I'm coming in hot.
Stranger.
Hello.
Can you stop moving for like two seconds?
Oh,
nope, that's up.
I need to go up.
I'm matching the velocity.
And we also found some secret...
Oh, wait.
Am I upside down again?
How does this keep happening to me?
Just roll.
Perfect landing.
We found some secret ways to get in.
I wonder if there's any other secret ways then, you know?
No?
Okay.
It's actually a great landing.
I know.
That's what I'm saying.
I always land perfectly.
On two feet.
I'm like a cat.
I can't see anything!
Oh my goodness.
Okay.
Turns out indeed does show during Intended Direct AP.
Oh!
It is!
Oh, we missed it!
Thanks for the info though, none.
Thank you.
What?
Stop!
Oh!
Oh, we're here!
Oh, we went inside this one!
I didn't even realize.
Okay.
Let's rotate this.
On the road again.
Sorry about the lock on.
No, it wasn't you, it was me, it was me.
It was me, it was me, it was me.
Jeffrey, don't apologize.
You have nothing to apologize for, buddy.
Look.
This one is not the one that I wanted to go to.
I believe.
This one?
No, I think it's further up the road.
Makes my stomach drop a little bit.
My stomach.
Yeah, I've been around here for quite a bit.
This part is so fun.
Okay, it's past here too.
I love the music here.
I also, I've noticed that there's like a backside to this.
A behind.
Towers got a big old behind.
No.
Oh, oh, be careful, be careful.
We gotta hurry before everything starts breaking apart.
Here!
There!
That's the one!
That's the one, right?
I believe.
Ah!
Oh god!
Maybe not this one.
Actually, maybe I'm a liar.
I'm a liar.
But there is that up there.
Wait a second.
Oh, yes!
No, this is the one.
This is the one.
I'm not a liar.
I've never lied.
But the gap...
That's right.
There's a big old gap.
What if we...
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Ouch!
We're fine!
Okay, I thought it was Minecraft rules.
Or if I land in the water, I'll be okay.
Come on!
Move!
Maybe I can propel myself up here.
A little bit.
Okay, nice.
And, whoop!
Nice.
Whoop!
Vitals are low, but does it really matter in the end?
Who needs bones?
Not me, I'm a ghost.
Um.
Hmm.
Oh, you...
Uh-oh.
Go eyes.
I don't like there's a way up here.
I heard it, though.
I hear that.
Where is that coming from?
Hmm, I guess we'll continue onward.
Oh.
Push, push, push.
Come, come, come, come, come.
Hmm.
This game is scary.
It's a little eerie, right?
Wow.
I mean, we saw some pretty freaky stuff before.
Oh, I thought that was a door right there.
Um...
Could there be another way?
What's over here?
here, actually.
Because...
I think there's only one way to get through here, right?
Like, where does this lead to?
Where am I crazy?
Go, go, go, power through!
Power, power, power!
Oh, it's not strong enough.
Hmm.
But how do we get over through there right that might be our
way what's over here
you might be crazy i might be crazy
so that's
because oh i see it right there we have to go on this side
and then very quickly go through here Because there's all
this stuff.
I don't think I've been to those, right?
Those buildings over there.
Hmm, I don't think so.
What if I just...
Where does it land?
Is it in the water?
I think it's in the water.
Oh!
Nice!
I can't tell at all if I've been...
here or not i can't tell even a little bit oh this might
have been a waste of a run but maybe not a total maybe not a
waste is dramatic to say right maybe because we learned well
nothing
i learned that i will try to get to these buildings there
can i climb through the trees like a monkey speaking a
monkey you guys uh-oh, I'm gonna die oh, I lived speaking of
monkeys I have a new high score in balloons which is like a
hundred and eighty something no monkey, no monkey no monkey
I think I'm gonna meditate
thank you for always being yourself meant.
Is that a good thing?
Thanks, Dylan.
Mm-hmm.
Actually, no.
I think I lied.
I think not 180.
I think it was 178.
But that's also closer to 200.
She lied.
I don't lie.
lie i've never lied i've never lied i've never lied
what about ice monkey though he's a given
yeah we
okay so we're going to go down that one and we're going to
go on the right side and we're going to keep to the right
keep to the right keep to the right keep to the right keep
to the right When she lies, her nose gets smaller.
Reverse Pinocchio.
Is it going to send us inside?
No.
There we go.
Coming in.
Coming in easy.
Am I upside down again?
I think I am.
Why am I always upside down?
Here I am.
Flip!
Do a flip!
I wonder...
Let's see.
Nice landing.
I think I'm a professional now, for real.
Oh, it is, it is, it is, it is, it is.
It is this one.
Oh, but it's not here.
Oh, man.
Ah!
Awesome.
Here we go, Al.
She's a professional now.
I know, I know, I know.
Okay.
This spooky little house.
He almost repeated the elevator incident.
Where was this house at, though?
Actually, I can't quite remember.
Oh no, wait, we're at the dam!
Oh...
Oh, shucks.
We need to go all... Oh, you know what?
That's fine.
Cowabunga!
Easy.
So maybe it wasn't the most effective way, but that's fine.
Oh, give me in.
Give me in.
Okay, here we go.
On the road again.
What was that about this not being Minecraft?
It wasn't.
I very much jumped into a deep pit of water.
Okay, not yet.
It's past there.
Okay.
Oh, I... Oh, whoops.
I see it.
Oh, goodness.
It's really tough.
to get all the way over there.
Okay.
We'll do our best.
Maybe if we, like, propel ourselves from over here.
Okay.
This way.
Over yonder, over yonder.
Okay, we got this.
We got this.
Just stick to the right.
Stick to the right.
There it is.
The hidden passageway.
Nice!
Okay.
Nice, nice, nice.
Okay, we're going to learn more things!
We're going to learn so much over here.
We're going to learn all the knowledge in the world over
here.
Oh, oh, to the right!
To the right!
There we go!
Nice.
Straight in the middle there.
So many eggs on the screen right now.
Stop!
Stop this!
Stop this humiliation, please!
What do we have over here?
An elevator.
Come down!
Oh, it's broken.
Just kidding.
Don't fall through.
But we have to find a way to get up there.
Okay, that's question number one.
Don't get crushed again.
We have a thing here and a ancient language.
This game be wild.
Yeah, it's so awesome though.
Oh, there we go.
Oh my goodness.
New places are so exciting to explore.
So exciting, so exciting.
Like, cups and such.
Minto Gear Solid 5.
The Phantom Egg.
Stop.
Oh, that's where we just came from.
Time to go see more culty activities!
This one.
Whoa!
There we go.
This way.
There better not be some dead guys down here, or else I'm
really going to start thinking that this is a cult.
I'm really, I'm really, I'm serious this time.
Uh-oh.
Wait.
Were they always wearing necklaces?
Or am I just now noticing that for the first time?
Okay.
We have to figure out what's going on here.
We're on definitely a time limit.
I mean, I've always been on a time limit, but we gotta know
what that sound is.
We gotta figure it out.
Koto.
What necklaces?
You didn't see them?
Oh, is this another...
Nice.
I have the artifact!
I wonder if I combine this...
with something.
I must combine it.
Oh wait, I need to get a...
Pick it up.
I need to go find a lantern, but I don't know where to get
one.
Oh!
Jojo Ko, happy birthday!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday dear Jojo Ko!
Happy birthday!
Oh, the cult room.
You're so right.
Let's go get a lantern.
I'm like 50 in the creeper room.
Right.
Okay.
There's a lot over here.
Oh, this is exciting.
There's so much going on over here.
Eek!
Play seal.
Now, can I combine the lantern with the artifact is my
question.
In fact, I'm going to go grab it real quick.
We're going to bring you upstairs.
You're mine.
Conceal.
Wait, what does that mean?
Oh, focus?
Interesting.
Didn't, um...
Sorry, hold on, I'm thinking.
Didn't we, um...
Conceal, don't feel, don't let them know.
Well, now they know.
Um, there was like one thing that we lit up that, um, that
showed like secret passageways and stuff.
Remember, it showed like the secret cave.
So I wonder if that is what that does.
Okay.
We're looking at this thing again.
So scary.
Oh gosh.
Again.
Okay, he lights it up.
The third one.
The third eye.
Okay, so the top one was the first eye.
The second one is the second eye.
The third one is the third eye.
Okay.
Why did I leave it on that one again?
It's so scary.
Oh, jeffrey.
Are you guys okay?
Why is this game...
Why is this DLC so much scarier than...
everything else.
That's the thing.
That's the artifact.
Dear guy is kind of giving portrait of God vibes.
Don't say that.
It'll scare me so much.
Stop!
Nano, what's wrong with you?
Ooh.
So, so they're looking.
Look at all of them standing.
They're like, wow, planets.
Boring.
Never mind.
Boring planets.
We hate planets.
Let's go watch TV instead.
Yeah, let's watch VTubers, hey boys.
Watching VTubers with the boys.
Oh, wait!
That guy!
That guy is the one that's missing an antler.
He was the one with his eyes scratched out.
He's blinking.
VTuber.
No, we hate those planets.
We're watching our own planets.
instead.
Our planet rocks.
Yeah, our planet's so cool.
Our planet's the best planet.
Oh, they're crying.
They miss their planet.
Oh, that's so sad.
Woo, our planet!
Our planet.
Oh, God, why did we leave our planet?
Oh, they're just, it's just, who's taking this video of them
crying about their planet?
Oh,
I have a feeling.
I use the artifact, like, on these slides.
Oh, I'm scared.
I'm scared.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Ah!
There's so many of them!
Oh, the room!
It's the room where they...
Where they...
Wait, can I light it with the...
Oh!
They're crying because their Oshie is late to stream.
No, who would cry over that?
Who would cry over that?
Oh!
Hello.
Oh, hello.
They're looking at me.
Good night.
And it lights up.
And I fall asleep.
They're asleep.
Okay.
Eepy baby.
Hmm.
So this guy...
If we take it into that room, what will happen?
Artifact does not fit.
Oh, wait.
No.
I'm afraid to see what happens.
Time to nap!
What if I go into the room that had the one...
the one bed that was open for me?
I'm scared, I'm scared, I'm scared, I'm scared, I'm scared,
I'm scared, I'm scared, I'm scared, I'm so scared.
Set on fire.
Light on fire.
Eat a marshmallow first.
Perfect.
Mmm, yummy.
Anyway.
Yeah, all of theirs are lit.
This guy.
But when the melatonin hits.
This guy too.
Dang.
Are there...
Oh, are there...
Spoilers?
I will not look.
I see you guys posting some...
What just happened?
Oh!
Oh, don't touch the fire so much, I guess.
Maybe I got a little too close.
I like that you guys do the four-eyes for this game.
died be careful out there okay let's continue onward for now
this is an elevator no no no up that does not go up only
goes down hey go down go down
Is this not where I...
Oh!
This is the elevator.
Okay, never mind.
Go up.
Go up elevator.
Yeah, this is the broken one.
Good to know.
This leads to nowhere.
No, I don't know how much time we have left.
Are those that, that's the, oh, the reels are all burned up
though.
It's all burned up.
Oh.
Uh.
Am I in, I was gonna say, am I in trouble?
Do we have to come back here when it's, um, when that
happens?
Uh oh.
Wait, no.
It won't flood here, will it?
Am I in trouble?
Uh oh.
Uh...
Am I in trouble?
Um...
Any rush of water?
Oh!
Here it comes!
Yeah!
I'll hide right here.
I hear it, I hear it, I hear it.
You're in so much trouble, little miss.
Oh!
I wonder if it floods in here, though.
Dang, it doesn't.
That's me!
Okay.
Bye-bye, bridge.
Oh, no!
We didn't get to go to that side!
Oh, man.
It also took the entire house down.
But we have this house to go into.
That entrance doesn't have radiation.
What do you mean?
I wonder if I do a picture mode.
Oh gosh.
That's like really close up.
Yeah.
Oh, I don't think I can go any further.
I don't think so.
For now.
For now, for now, for now.
Does this eat?
Wait, it's the same color.
Focus.
I don't want to die, though.
When we're at the end, when we're towards the end, I'll come
back and try it.
I think.
We'll just leave it there for now.
I want to look inside this place real quick.
Oe!
can.
Wow, nice place you got here.
Why is it locked?
What are you hiding?
Huh?
An axe!
What are you hiding?
Do after the music starts.
Yeah, something like that.
There's a whole lot of nothing.
There's a whole lot of nothing in here.
Just kidding.
Oh my god, I'm so scared.
Wait, that's a thing right there!
That's a...
That's a reel.
I'm so scared of seeing somebody.
Right there!
We need that.
Yeah, a slide reel.
I wonder if I can get the door from up here.
Like, you know, with the light.
Maybe here.
Launch.
Oh, nice, nice, nice, nice, nice.
Okay.
Take it back.
Too slow.
No, launch.
Take it back.
Launch.
Yippee!
I told you guys I'm so smart.
Minto Tensai.
I know.
I know I am.
Oh, this is a new picture.
They're playing...
Oh my gosh, they're literally playing 4D chess.
Minto Tensai.
The...
Projection room was over here.
That honestly took me way longer to figure out.
Oh, it depends on the person.
How long it'll take you.
I have my moments of strokes of genius, okay?
Um...
Take you.
Drop.
Insert.
Moving car.
Thanks for the gift.
Incoming four hours for one puzzle.
That's why I'm saying there's strokes of genius.
What is this?
It's something.
It's a gate.
Why is the music so scary?
Why
is the music so scary?
I'm trying to tell what's that at the bottom.
There's so many of these.
There's nine of them.
Minto matter.
Huh?
Ah!
Oh, I can't read it.
Wee-woo, wee-woo.
Okay, something bad happened to it, huh?
I just got chills down my spine.
The music is so eerie.
It makes me quite afraid.
Um, I'm observing each slide, each little individual pixel.
Okay, it's scaring me, so I'm gonna just let that be.
We got the ship log updated, at least.
Is that an egg?
Yes!
How'd you know?
How much time do you think we have left?
There's also...
That's... Oh!
Oh, that's the...
That's another artifact.
The little lantern symbol.
Do you think I can make yet?
Hmm.
You think I can make yet?
You can totally make it.
do it for science but what about this guy this is our first
time finding an artifact that we can pick up what if I bring
the real in here though because it's it's the real room for
real homies only hold on gonna go get the real and see what
happens because it's the real room the room of reels like
this one we'll just pick up this one wait this one already
was all burnt up wasn't it we'll take this one what would
that accomplish though it could I think we have to burn it
so then once we use the artifact we can see new things on
the reel on the slides that because this one had no burns on
it right so I think it will reveal more stuff when we use
the artifact.
Yee.
Uh-oh.
Oh, it's time!
It's time!
Nope.
Drop!
Okay, I need to get it all closer.
Ah!
Drop!
Okay, that didn't do anything.
Oh, I died.
I died.
Okay, well, we know that didn't do anything.
You dropped dead.
Wait,
there's more to explore in that area, though.
Boom.
Oh,
you know what I watched recently, um, on the plane, I
watched, um, I talked about it before on stream, but I've
been thinking about it quite, quite a bit, was, uh, all you
need is kill, but what's, I can't remember the English name.
Not Top Gun, not this time.
Edge of Tomorrow, yes, yes.
And every time, like, every time in this game when you're
like...
It reminds me of when you like wakes up in Edge of Tomorrow.
I really like that movie.
I really liked it.
Live, die, repeat.
I love time travel.
I love things where you have to die and relive the same day.
Groundhog's Day is up.
Hmm.
You're playing the my Tom Cruise.
An enormous reservoir with wooden pe- Oh, wait, that's the
same thing.
Whole breach.
Oh, I found a slide reel in the hidden gorge that showed an
explosion blowing a hole in the side of the stranger.
Yeah, that's totally what that showed.
Does that mean we should enter from there?
Instead of entering...
That's... See, okay, that bottom part down there?
I was like, oh, that kind of looks like the entrance I've
been going in every time.
Ah!
I did recognize it.
I was like, that's why I was looking at it.
I was like, I think it looks like the part where I've been
entering from entering the stranger at.
A narrow gorge along the rightmost branch of the river.
their dwellings built into both cliff faces high above
several reels a slide reel that shows the strangers
inhabitants congregating around a strange green fire several
slides have been burned and cannot be viewed a slide reel
from the hidden gorge showed a glowing symbol and the chains
appear around a strange fault oh scary don't forget to read
the lines.
Oh, you're right.
There are line things, too, aren't there?
Oh, whoops.
A slide rail from the hidden gorge shows a glowing symbol
and chains appear around a strange vault.
Slide rail from the cinder aisles show a glowing symbol and
chains appear around.
It's just the same thing over and over again.
Wait, what?
Slide rail from the river lowlands showed a strange vault
being closed and sealed with chains and a glowing symbol.
I like, yeah, I really do like that it shows the reels
because then I don't have to go back and find them all over
again.
The reservoir.
There's more to explore here.
Oh, in the, okay.
The reservoir.
Yes, because there's that house that we haven't been able to
go into.
I wonder if I can figure, there was the doors that were
locked.
I wonder if it's similar to the puzzle I just did with the
light, like shooting my little scout in there.
Okay.
Solid Mint!
That's me!
I played this DLC and it did not have that feature.
Yay!
For quality of life updates!
Yippee!
Getting the reals to play back in the ship vlog was an
unusually hard problem to solve for later DLC badges.
I want to Try real quick though, I do want to go back to
that one spot, but I want to try and find the explosion
part, the part that blew up, right?
It was...
Wait, if I'm looking at it upside down, okay, hold on.
It's on...
It's up here, right?
It's like...
Eep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep.
Oh, over here.
I'm getting all topsy-turvyed.
Up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up, up.
Up, up, up, up, up.
Oopsie.
We're fine.
Everything's okay.
Um.
This side.
Oh!
We're okay.
Gosh, stranger.
Oh, I can't move to the right.
I can't.
I can't...
I can only move...
I can only move a little bit forward.
Oh.
No.
Uh...
Yep.
You know what?
I'm just gonna land right here.
Let's go look at the log real quick.
Um...
Um, where was it?
Okay.
Okay, it's the very outmost.
And it's...
Oh my gosh, it goes so fast.
It goes so fast.
I need to see the whole thing.
Ship's a little roughed up.
It's okay, we can fix it.
Okay.
I think I got it.
Oh!
Goodbye, ship!
um uh uh over this one maybe do i have a flashlight on or
what why don't i have a flashlight this is fine
this one ouch um
Where'd my ship go anyway?
Oh.
All the way over there.
It's that one up there, is it not?
No.
Up.
Up, up, up.
Girl is so lost.
No.
I'm not.
It's this one.
In the corner.
Don't run into it.
Right here.
But my flashlight's not working for some reason.
Um.
Wait, what just happened?
Huh?
What just happened?
Did I go too fast?
I was coming in a little hot.
I came in a little high.
Sometimes it's really hard to tell how fast you're going
when you feel like you're just going so slow.
Okay, one more time.
Oh, wait, no.
Okay.
A tad high.
We got it this time, though.
Remind us not to accept rides from you.
Look!
It's harder, it's harder to tell when you're not using your
actual body.
I think I would know how fast I was going if I was using my
real body.
My spirit.
Okay.
Let's see.
If we're looking at it, so it's that one over there, right?
Perhaps.
Perhaps it's this one.
I'm going to land slowly.
Keep the velocity matched.
Land slow.
Can I even land, actually?
I don't even know.
Oh!
Yeah!
Perfect!
It's that one right there, right?
I think so.
Please be it.
Oh.
Did I find it?
Wait.
What's going on?
What just happened?
I didn't find it.
Oh, now...
Oh, shoot.
I think I'm lost again.
You guys...
That was really weird.
And my flashlight has stopped working again!
Okay.
What's happening?
Why can't I move?
I'm trapped.
Okay, there we go.
Ouch.
I can't...
You scout for light?
Okay, that's a good plan.
You guys are so smart.
I don't know why my flashlight has stopped working, though.
I can't even find it.
I'm so confused.
It's here?
Maybe.
Ah!
Oh, I made it.
I lived.
But I don't see the hole.
Oh.
Huh.
I don't even...
Why am I sideways?
How do I fix myself?
Oh, road... Wait, how do I fix myself you guys i'm sideways
and i don't know how to get up outer edge okay i'm sideways
oh over here
i'm sideways i keep go scout go why am i being pushed away
so far
Help me!
I'm afraid you're unfixable.
Shut up!
How do we get in there?
50% fuel remaining.
Oh, this is such a mistake.
I'm trying to go down!
But I come in too hot!
Okay, okay, here we go.
Oh, wrong down.
I'm stuck.
This thing is so...
Yes.
Oh no, I didn't mean to take the scout back.
I'm trapped in a hole.
Why is this thing so large?
Oh my god.
Ouch.
Hole, please.
I'm inside!
I got it.
Leave.
I don't like that.
Oh.
Okay.
Open up.
What's this?
Oh.
It's a working thing.
I think.
Wait.
Huh?
Close the door.
It's going to show me secrets.
Oh, my bad.
Wait.
Close.
Close the door.
It's gonna show me secrets.
I think my scout is ruining it.
There's no secrets.
No secrets.
Okay, interesting.
Hello?
Oh.
Where are we?
Actually.
Uh-oh.
The light thing just happened.
Where are we?
Oh, new picture.
Nice.
Cute little.
Hmm.
There are secrets somewhere.
There are two...
We discovered.
Oh.
Stop, stop.
I keep grabbing that.
Put it away.
Oh!
Grab it.
Sit down.
Lock yourself in.
Look at the fire.
Close your eyes.
Become one with the fire.
And...
Okay!
I guess I'll do that.
Sounds good.
Oh, okay, I see now.
So this part was damaged, but what happened in here?
There was an explosion.
So now we know what this room is for.
What happened in here?
What caused the explosion, you know?
Maybe it's a toilet.
Oh, for some reason I thought, wait, was one of these fires
lit or am i crazy i
think i'm crazy oh i'm getting absorbed again let me leave
no let me leave okay there we go i'm trying to grab the
artifact i don't think it really matters
okay what if what about the other one oh
side reel okay we're definitely gonna have to come back here
because I took too much time getting in here because I was
lost.
What about this one?
A regular lantern.
And you sit down.
And you close the door.
And then you close your eyes.
And you see the fuzzies.
It also works with a regular lantern, I guess.
Oh.
Okay.
Interesting.
There's the regular one.
Let's head out.
Oh,
just a window.
That's what an idiot would say.
Just a blank?
No.
Nothing is ever just a blank.
Where are we?
Oh!
the other side!
And the the bridge is intact!
Yippee!
There's like shortcuts everywhere.
Okay, I was thinking, oh, I should have taken the boat in
there, but actually it's good that I didn't.
Okay, cool.
Let's go in here.
We need to hurry because We need to go...
In fact, I'm gonna drop this here.
And I'm gonna go get a lantern right now.
Before this bridge disappears.
Let's go get it.
Run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run, run,
run, run, run, run, run, run.
I think you're fine on time.
I don't think so.
I think it's actually close-ish because the electricity
thing happened, which we still don't know.
What that is.
Still not sure.
Was this always there?
She has no confidence.
Have confidence.
Yeah, I gotta listen for the damn break.
Hmm?
Do you...
Okay.
Lamp.
Grab.
Grab it.
Firmly grasp it.
Show your friends.
Lock yourself in the room.
Be a little voyeur and observe.
Fall asleep.
Melatonin.
Wake up really quickly.
Speed nap.
Never mind.
Oh, use the artifact.
Do the same thing.
Fall asleep.
speed run.
I can see, like, lanterns very slightly.
Like, the lamps.
Something's going on in there.
Oh, is that the explosion?
Trees?
That's so hard to tell what's going on.
Oh.
Grab this thing.
Observe.
Speed nab.
Yes.
This is the thing.
It can't be a lantern or a circle.
It must be that.
Okay.
Interesting.
So these ones here.
The one with the little...
Spikies.
Hi, cutie.
I hope you're doing well.
Dust call my wife!
I hope you're doing well, too.
We have to fall asleep in a room.
With the artifact.
Do we have to grab the artifact that one room made for one
where was it it's at the very beginning though right
I don't think I definitely don't think I have time for it
now but we'll try grab you it was try the room nearer to you
I needed like a chair to fall asleep in I think... Actually,
no, I don't think I took this in there, did I?
Well, I think about it.
Oh my god, cult party!
Hey guys!
Everybody ready to slumber!
Oh god!
I'm scared!
I thought we were buddies!
I thought we were buddies to slumber!
What are we screaming at?
Cold slumber party!
Official welcome to the DLC part 2!
Ah, Jeffrey!
I'm scared!
I can't even use my... I just realized I can't even use my
thing.
I can't use my suit!
Oh my god.
Oh,
I'm lighting up the...
There's like little candles.
I'm lighting them up.
What?
Wow!
I'm on their planet!
What?
I think?
It's really dark.
I can't see anything.
That's why I keep focusing, because I can't see anything.
Okay.
Light up.
Light up, light up.
This is...
Oh!
There's nothing dangerous in here!
Wow!
At least they didn't draw on your face and sharpie him.
it's so cool because i never used the doze off thing but
then i was like wait a second i can doze off here for real i
can doze off here that's what they they keep telling me to
fall asleep and that's what i did and it worked what where
is everybody um oh they're they're musical creatures
Developers cooked.
I know.
Because in the main game, it just feels like a way to kind
of like pass time if you need.
If you need it.
If you want to have things go faster.
It's actually like a mechanic here.
It's so cool.
Okay, I'll go downstairs.
I'll search down here first.
I just heard a door open.
I'm scared.
Guys, are there jump scares in this?
Be honest.
I'm freaking out a little bit.
Oh, that's a tree.
It's not there.
I don't remember jump scares.
I do remember regular scares.
there is a setting for reduced fright there is there is
actually a setting for that i
got grabby grabbed wait oh um i guess i guess i saw
everything there that i wanted to see
there's someone there
this place i don't think we're alone you guys he's he's
watching vtubers
afraid i'm a little afraid oh god
wait i'm gonna meditate until next loop so there's still
loops then are there their family
will they actually kill me
What's this out?
Oh god, I'm so scared.
There's something in here.
But I can't go in.
Oh wait.
Is this...
No way!
The loop music!
It's so faint!
Why?
it's it's him below I think it's this guy how do I get in
there I'm trying to go say hi to him I don't know how they
play music they can't be bad right wait is this where I came
from I'm a little confused I'm getting a little lost
So we are still technically...
Gosh, do these people not believe in light?
How are you supposed to see all the time?
This is... okay.
Okay, that's...
That's nighttime.
So?
Looks like a creature that's Like, bleh, bleh, bleh, bleh.
Bleh, bleh, bleh, bleh, bleh, bleh.
Okay, we're going to die at any second.
There it is.
Okay.
What the heck?
Heck, heck.
So, I'm guessing also...
If I...
do this at a separate little area, like a separate cult
area, I will awaken in a different spot.
So let's try.
You really figured out a lot that loop.
Yeah, we did for real.
And then there should be more to explore, right?
Damage laboratory.
Oh, I feel like we got so much more than we actually that
it's actually showing a laboratory with three test chambers
a second chamber is badly damaged and can be entered through
a whole breach in the side of the stranger oh i saw a vision
like recording of someone picking up an artifact and going
to sleep in front of a green fire the rest of the vision was
distorted and difficult to make out but a flame seemed to
appear inside that artifact i found a slide reel oh oops my
bad that shows three experiments conducted with three
different artifacts.
The third experiment appears to have been a success.
And here.
A massive canyon that stretches into the distance.
A candlelit lodge is built into the far cliff face.
There's more to explore here.
But also, there's more to explore here at the reservoir.
So maybe we should go back here.
In fact, I think we...
I think...
There was another...
Cult place there.
So...
That's a pretty good place to start.
I agree, I agree.
Oh my gosh!
This DLC is crazy!
I was like, I was like, it's a little eerie, but like, I'm
not seeing what's so scary about it.
Now I'm terrified!
Thanks a lot.
The team.
Thanks a lot, team.
Oh, we're coming in hot.
Yep.
The roll never...
Oh.
Ah.
Oopsie.
Oh, God.
Sorry, I didn't mean to kill you through suffocation.
Whoopsie!
Oh, no!
Thank you for membership.
There we go.
I'm playing along, did the same thing.
Have I ever used the eject function on the ship cockpit?
I haven't.
I don't think so.
Here we go!
My welcome to my bishop, thank you!
Bravery duck, thank you!
I believe that mint will find the egg.
I think so, too.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Coming in a little hot.
Alright, we're gonna roll, everybody.
Roll!
Perfect.
There we go.
I like watching my shadow over here.
Everything is so big and so small at the same time.
Okay, cool.
This is where we need to be.
This is the ravine.
And we're going down, going down the bayou, going down the
bayou,
taking it all the way.
You guys stop saying there's an egg, only I can see them,
okay?
Anyone who says that they see an egg is a liar.
The egg is only through Minto vision.
This one.
Now...
Is the guy...
Is the guy that we're seeing...
In the other world?
Is he the one that didn't go to sleep?
Uh-oh.
I have to go find an artifact.
So that's what I'm on the way to look for.
Artifacts!
Um...
Maybe...
It was in here.
Artifact.
That's a real...
Oh!
Be hatched from the egg.
I see an egg head in the bottom right.
Ay, ay, ay, ay, ay, ay, ay, ay, ay, ay.
Was there an artifact around here or...
Are we gonna have to go searching a little bit?
What did you not explore here while it was dry?
That's a great question.
I don't remember.
Up here perhaps?
No, this just leads to a boat.
It's there, damn it.
I'm answering.
Hi, Mint.
First time of year.
Hello!
Thanks for dropping by.
Hello, hello, hello.
We're playing spooky game.
I'm a little frightened.
Right now I have seen the artifact!
You are so correct.
I do remember.
We have to return to the egg location.
It was under the water.
Or no, it wasn't.
Murphy, thanks for the 10 gift.
Thank you.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
If I go down here.
Minecraft logic, Minecraft logic, Minecraft logic.
We're fine.
Everything's good.
Uh, uh.
Maybe not the best location for that.
Um.
Whoa, oh my god, my eyes!
Wait a second.
Um, maybe I can go there?
Okay.
What?
Okay, we're safe.
There it is.
Oh no!
It's like...
Oh, just kidding.
Okay, bye.
Just kidding.
Everything's fine.
Egg.
Did you see it?
Oh, hello.
Hello.
Did you see it?
There's more to explore here.
But I feel like I mean not in this creepy area way, right?
Who?
Wait, this isn't the one.
This isn't the one that's missing a guy.
Okay, interesting.
I don't, where, which one was that then?
Time to doze off.
Time to wake up!
That was the other tower they won't even let me roast a
marshmallow here okay focus also why do i need to conceal
sometimes i don't like that i don't like that at all is
there stealth in this be honest give it to me now give it to
me straight if there is i'm gonna cry
oh there we are in a different location
What did I miss?
Did she redact or redact yet?
Probably one of those.
There is actually sneaking in this.
Oh my gosh.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no, no, no.
My least favorite thing ever is...
Is horror game sneaking.
It's actually one of my least favorite things.
Oh, no, no, no.
Oh, no, no, no, no.
I have bad news.
Popping in to say hi before I get sucked into a black wall
of work.
Music.
Thanks for the super chat.
I hear whistling.
It's coming from this way, though.
I can't help but be silent because I'm so scared.
I'm so scared.
Is it breathing?
Do I hear breathing?
Okay, let's just keep going.
I'm so scared.
I'm so scared, you guys.
It's cool.
Let's just follow the lights.
I'm scared.
Why are these guys evil, though?
Why are these guys gonna want to kill me?
Wait, uh...
How do I get up there?
Guess we're going down.
Who says they're evil?
Well then what's trying to kill- what's gonna kill me?
It's all in your head.
You never think how cute it is that she's always bringing
her over here?
My tummy's starting to hurt.
extinguish.
Okay.
Why can't I extinguish them?
Why?
What's over there?
Me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me, me.
Do you guys hear that?
There's something walking in the water.
Wait, how do I get back up?
Uh-oh.
Wait, I don't know how to get it back up.
Do you...
Monster...
Monster, can you show me how to get up there?
Hello?
Don't say hello back?
Ah!
I think that was the damn breaking.
What just happened?
Huh?
Oh my god, I'm trapped in a bell.
Where am I trapped?
Oh gosh.
Uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, that's, I
don't think I can get out from there.
Oh, ah!
Get me out of here!
There's bodies!
Did I get caught?
Oh my god, did I get caught?
You do not recognize the body.
Oh, he's in the water.
Um, now what?
Now what?
I'm expecting to get jump scared from Mint getting jump
scared.
I'm sorry.
That's just what happens, you know.
I scream, you scream.
Oh, wait!
Wait!
I think my fire went out!
Oh, I think my fire, I think the water wait but i didn't
walk into water did i
the water in here the water in here
the water walked into you did it like did did exterminating
this fire cut it out or something aha
I see so maybe the tower I need a boat come here maybe the
tower will be free of excuse me I'm hopping in oh let me in
let me in please thank you okay The tower there.
That's the one that was missing the person, though, right?
Don't play this carefree music as if you didn't just scare
the shit out of me before.
Don't just act like this is some funky river boat ride.
Don't act like everything's normal.
Don't be like this.
It's like, la la la, so whimsical.
Here.
Wait, how do I get up there?
And then we have to do it before the tower falls, because
this falls down, I remember.
We don't have much time then, I think.
I don't think we have much time.
Jump, IDK.
Uh, uh, uh.
Wait.
It falls right at the end of the cycle?
Okay.
There.
I'm too scared for this.
I'm too much of a baby
Where are we now is a better question Oh Oh Interesting Oh
Hello If you're gonna kill me and just do it now Pull me out
of my misery
You guys there's actually stealth in this don't lie to me
please be honest be honest I'm too scared oh I don't like
the whistling you play metal gear I'm sure you're fine I
don't like stealth I've said that since the beginning I've
always said that that.
What's this music?
What's going on?
Where's going on?
Maybe I should go down.
Hmm.
Okay.
They're on to you.
Stop!
Oh wait, I can't go down.
I just realized.
Can I see it from here?
I can't.
Nothing here.
Ah!
No!
Oh god!
Ah!
Oh gosh.
Get me out of here.
There we go.
Ah.
Oh.
What did you do this time?
It wasn't me!
Ah.
We didn't get to explore very much there.
We learned so much.
I guess we did learn that if you...
If the water...
If the fire goes out in this world, then it goes out...
It goes out and then we get forcefully removed.
Okay.
So next loop will come to this tower.
Next loop will come to this tower.
I'm so scared, though.
I'm too scared.
Brain is bad.
bigger.
Do something cool before it's over.
Nice jump.
Nice egg.
Wee!
Are we good?
Are we gonna?
There it is.
I know I can meditate, but I like listening to the music.
Oh, I just gleeced all over the place.
Nasty.
I am feeling a bit better today, though, so I think that's
good.
Maybe I'm getting better.
Huh?
Yeah, I gleeced.
the membership thank you guys can i just stay here slate the
world this the universe is too terrifying i don't like it
anymore meaties fries minced eyes hot dog surprise thank you
i can glee on the gun command on demand all these people are
demanding me to glee Do you gleek ectoplasm?
Just a little bit, yeah.
Ooh, she's got bars.
Alex, welcome to Mammoth Show.
Thank you!
I can't stop yawning though, I think because I...
I woke up early.
It was a busy day today for me.
Oh shoot!
I forgot to check though.
Okay, hold on.
Once we get inside...
Oh my goodness, coming in hot, coming in hot!
And roll.
Nice.
There was one thing I forgot to check though.
Here.
Interesting.
Mint, can you gleek please?
I can't do it on command!
A secluded village nestled within a cave.
A candlelit tower sits atop a nearby island.
I can't tell what anything is because everything is so dark.
A dense forest along the banks of a river.
Okay, this is the one that I couldn't get back up on the...
The what's it called?
The bridge after we did it.
How am I supposed to... Maybe I'm supposed to jump.
I don't know.
Okay.
And we still have this cliffside building that we couldn't
make it to.
The bridge, yeah, had rotted away.
And wherever this sealed vault is.
And the reservoir still says there's more to explore here.
Oh, my God.
I'm so sorry.
What more is there to explore in the reservoir?
Oh, the reservoir.
Just kidding.
the first area that we came out of.
Hello, universe.
Let's come take me back.
I'm so sorry, everybody.
too much universe.
Yeah, that's the reservoir.
I keep thinking this is the reservoir right here.
To the tower.
Because we'll have the most amount of time to explore.
There.
So I want to go back.
What did you think?
I didn't think I was going to force me off.
I thought maybe I would just be looking at the universe.
I thought maybe.
Stop judging me, everybody.
Okay, look at all these eggs.
Nice.
There's one around here, but I forget which house it's in.
What do you mean one around here?
An egg?
Oh, the artifact.
Yes, we must find one.
Shoot.
I thought an egg.
I've only got egg on the brain, everybody.
I can find it, though.
Yeah, see?
This guy with his antler broken off.
Do you think he's the one that, um...
Do you think he is the one that's stalking the night?
I have to wonder.
My throat is starting to hurt.
Oh no.
They said you abandoned us.
So they crossed out his picture.
He's not worthy any longer.
Is there one around here?
Really glad I tuned into the stream.
Didn't realize they made DLC for Egg-Eggos of the Eye.
um you can backseat if you want to tell me where if anybody
knows where it's at just so we can progress
is that a baby small small there's no one there's none here
I don't think there's any artifacts here oh no the one in
the ghost matter building upstream.
Oh, no!
Oh, shoot.
So we came all this way for nothing.
Okay, so now we know the order of operations must be...
Grab artifact.
Head to tower.
Dummy tea.
Eggos.
I wonder if I can...
In the upstream or in the canyon village?
If I go upstream, how do I get back here?
Wait.
Was there anything else over here?
I don't think so, right?
Come on.
You can make it.
We weren't traveling fast enough for the music to believe we
were playing the game.
It's a loop.
but...
It was here, right?
Oh, wait.
Wait, I'm confused again.
What is that thing?
What is destroying the power?
Please, please, please, please, please, please, please,
please, please, please, please.
Please, please, please, please, please, please.
I think I went to the wrong place.
Oh, shoot.
I'm a little lost, I think.
I think I'm a little lost.
Yes, hold it.
Yes.
Actually, I do want to see this place again.
Because, um...
This is where...
This is where, uh...
I wonder if we can use the scout.
here.
Go over the dam and grab it.
Yeah, I think I'm gonna have to.
Because it says there's more to explore in here.
But can we...
Is there like a mirror or something?
Maybe
here?
No.
Hang out on the lake a bit next time you come through the
transition from one theme to in the other is my favorite but
it sounds...
You're like, hey, can you just, like, not play the game for
a second?
Oh, wait, here!
Maybe.
Uh...
Wait a second.
Does that mean I have to go in under the water?
Aha!
Ah!
Okay, good stuff.
There we go.
Okay, we finally made it in here.
Yippee!
Wait, there was a lantern here.
Oh, sorry.
Oh, it's inside!
Oh my gosh.
It's inside that bell tower thing.
Oh this the the seal the safe good info we got some actual
good info here come on don't be so picky okay and this this
that is it there was a way to lift it perhaps control it in
some way?
Okay.
That was a good, that was a pretty big find, I'd say.
Hmm, hmm, hmm, hmm.
Which maybe we wait for it to drain.
Or?
Not.
Oh, maybe we should wait for it to drain.
Or?
Not.
Oh, oh, oh.
Oh,
if I had an artifact here, oh shoot, okay, if I had, Matara
Khan, if I had an artifact here,
this is where we will doze off next.
Oh, and it's safe from water, you're right.
Hazard, ghost matter it is made of ghost matter actually no
wonder it looks like it okay what's up thank you thank you
for the podcast it's been really helping me through my
workday thank you dawn thank you I'm glad you're enjoying it
thank you for listening okay um guys you'll have to remind
me how do i get up there we go you have to remind me where
another artifact was there wasn't one over here right i
think we have to wait for the dam to break maybe oh
there was one by the egg yes yes maybe i shouldn't wait
maybe i should just go I think I'm gonna fly down.
I think I'm just gonna fly down.
Oh, never mind!
Uh, here we go!
Kapush!
Look at it lowering.
So cool!
So, so cool.
So I'm guessing whatever powers off, or whatever happens,
here is what causes the wait it's here right where is the
ghost matter place ghost matter where's the matter oh
there it is okay nice I'm guessing whatever explodes or like
messes with the power is what causes the um the dam to break
that's my hypothesis also so the ghost matter is nullified
by water so that would make sense why the fire is also
can i do i have to loop all i think i have to loop let's go
let's let's go quickly I haven't watched much because I
still want to play the game myself, but I hope you're doing
well.
Stop by, send some love and support.
Thank you, Kinky!
It's getting crazy.
Oh, oh, that's a tree.
I thought it was just a bush.
Is it normal fire and low-lified by water, though?
Well, we didn't know what the ghost matter was before.
So, you know...
You know, it's...
It's, it's, you know...
So it's a ghost fire.
A willowisp.
I'm starting to get kind of hungry.
Over.
Ah!
Okay.
Now here's where it's tricky because the...
It seems a little strong here.
Oh my god, we're gonna doze off in here.
And it's not gonna be some terrifying thing.
Some, the creepy guys, right?
It's gonna be normal, probably.
It's gonna be great.
It's gonna be less scary than the other ones.
Because the guys disappear in the other ones.
Good night!
Matara gone.
There's an elevator.
Okay,
okay, I guess we gotta go down.
A hole.
Aha!
Wait!
Those are the locks!
For Matara!
We're gonna lock her up.
Use interface.
Oh no, I don't know the password.
Oh,
I don't know the password.
Okay.
That's...
Well, good to...
Oh, there she is.
Hi!
Secret language.
Rotate.
Oh.
There?
What's there?
I'm seeing I'm having visions you guys I'm having some crazy
visions there
take that uh-huh
okay in the tower fall asleep good night
uh-huh wait what
what what did that mean where are the subtitles mr.
meaty cougar welcome to membership thank you I got stuck on
this for like two hours that was a little confusing
wee-woo hi hi hi hi hi hi I was I was busy there excuse you
I was working on stuff.
I'll just go back.
Who are you to stop me, huh?
Yeah, that's right.
I'm just gonna go back.
Oh.
Oh, the good, yeah.
We're fine.
Let me actually wake you up.
Alright.
Maybe if I conceal my flame instead.
I'm not sure...
Oh, the candles are still lit and everything.
I guess they stay that way for the cycle.
How do we get the codes for these?
Hello?
Oh, it's time, everybody.
I believe it's time.
Run!
Just go!
Just run!
Oh,
so cool!
It goes to the normal music now.
Nah, we'll listen to the music.
And then I'll die.
Beem.
Marshmallow at the end of the world.
You know it.
And cooked to perfection.
Actually, I prefer mine burnt.
Eat 10 burnt marshmallows!
Mmm, carcinogens is the achievement.
Ugh.
Huh?
Oh.
That was weird.
I meditated and I woke up in the other world.
Because you slept at the fire.
I meditated at the fire.
Wait, can I do that instead of just looping?
I mean, instead of dozing off?
Very cool.
It's a nice little touch, right?
Submerged structure.
Subterranean...
Subterranean animism?
Subterranean lake.
A large metal structure is suspended by chains.
It can be entered by swimming from below.
There is a sealed vault illuminated by a green fire inside
the structure.
I discovered a vast subterranean lake beneath the submerged
structure.
is resting on the shore of the lake there are three
interfaces each marked with one of the three symbols from
the vault i rotated the mechanism in front of the vault
causing it to strain against the chains holding it shut
moments later rays of green light spilled out of the vault
we're just gonna totally ignore the the hallucinations i got
it i got it i got you
oh i found a strange vault wrapped in chains and marked with
three glowing symbols reel from river lowlands showed oh yes
oh wait wait wait um slide reel from the hidden gorge showed
a glowing symbol and chains appear around a strange vault
okay the light coming out from the vault gave me a vision oh
here it is here's our vision a vision of climbing a spiral
staircase to a room near the top of a tower one of the
strangers inhabitants pointed at a mural of an planet.
Then picked up an artifact and carried it downstairs to a
room with a green fire.
Sometime later, two of the lamps in the mural room turned
off, plunging the mural into darkness and revealing a secret
passage.
The passage led to three wooden containers, each marked with
a glowing vault seal.
Okay.
So, what?
What I'm... Can I just move?
the... the... the... the... the... let's go back to that
tower and check it out.
Seems like some people are saying that they are getting
stuck on this part.
We'll see if we can figure it out.
Because it's... I have to go?
Wait.
If I... go down with the artifact, do I have to fall asleep?
I'm not quite sure.
Okay.
We'll experiment.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Velocity.
Coming in hot, coming in hot.
Eating Mike Tyson's ass.
Thanks for two months!
And thanks for the five gifted!
He's eating ass!
Will it always be Mike Tyson's ass or...
Is that just what you prefer?
We'll forever be MTA.
Okay, um...
We'll just use the raft.
Go over here.
In fact, I'll just dock.
I'm quite good at that.
It will always be Mike Tyson.
Understandable.
Minecraft, physics.
Oh, ouch.
We're fine.
Grab that.
See ya.
Important game breaking spoilers.
Mint's cute.
Oh, how do I get back up to my boat?
Oh, just kidding.
Okie dokie.
Let's ignore that spoiler.
Mods, ban the spoiler.
Ban the person that spoils.
We're going back to the tower.
The tower to the tower.
Over here.
This is where we were trying to do before, wasn't it?
Okay.
Here we go.
I don't remember what was in this cave.
Actually can't quite remember.
Oh, that's right, the secret stairs.
Can I like...
Wee!
Okay, we're just gonna...
We're just gonna brute force it here.
Nice.
Alright, nice.
So basically he goes and looks at the picture.
He says, nice, picture.
And then he goes down and lights the fire.
And then he...
goes back up.
Should we think calling Minto Cute as a spoiler is like
saying Romeo and Juliet is a tragedy.
Being a tragedy is a spoiler or no.
What do you mean?
I saw this one.
Yes, yes, yes.
Okay, so we need these to go out eventually.
Okay, so I'm looking at it.
Wow.
I'm looking.
I'm viewing.
Okay.
What's up here?
The top of the world.
Oh, that's right.
Here.
This is the one spot we haven't gone to, I think.
You think I can just jump?
I think it's fine.
Whee!
Let's go over here.
It sounds like it's coming from over here.
Like the sound.
But this thing doesn't stop spinning.
Does it?
No, I don't think so.
It's the egg.
Enough with the egg!
No, I'm still spinning.
I feel
like I'm not doing this correctly, but I'm still, there's an
attempt.
Come on, use your legs.
Come on!
Do I doze off?
Oh!
I hate being here.
I can't extinguish it.
Oh lordy, I hate being here.
I hate this so much.
So, this is the tower.
We have to get back some...
Wait, can I just...
Can I just wake up?
And then I go back up, right?
Yeah.
So then we go...
Wait!
Oh, ew!
Okay.
Let's see if this worked.
Maybe?
I'm not sure?
Oh, wrong way.
My eyes become wide when I'm focusing.
It's because I'm scared.
Stop it.
Sorry they have big buggy eyes.
No!
It didn't work.
Hmm.
destroy it
destroy launch launch this
one took
me a while these are different types of lamps so I don't
think they break in the water I mean they should when the
whole tower comes down but you know
Do I have to spend more time in there or something or maybe
the more lights, well no, I was going to say the more lights
I light up in there, the ones turn out turn off out here.
Does the tower on the other side have a room like this too?
I don't think I could access it if it does.
but I think the it's this door that opens though right
because it's this is the one that it showed it said that the
lanterns turned off in here and then the door opened up in
here
true but it did show the guy carrying the artifact out what
like it was lit up I can't remember
It gets me every time.
I wish I could see the logs.
Oh, I wish I could see the logs.
Big yawn.
Oh, maybe.
Also, my throat's starting to hurt.
a little bit.
Not a little bit, a lot of bit.
Check the reel.
The one that I just left?
It'd be convenient in here, especially since it's tough to
get back to the ship.
Yeah, I think that's the only thing.
If I have to meditate, that's okay.
Oops.
What was in here?
Can't remember.
You've seen the reel.
Yeah, I know.
But I have to like look at it again.
Oh yeah, okay.
Ah.
I could go get it and look at it here.
Try and figure it out.
Let's just do that.
Is it this one?
Wait, is it this reel?
I don't think it is, right?
It's not this one, right?
This one just shows...
I think that one showed...
Okay, I think we need to look at the other one.
Because that one, if I remember correctly, it shows how to
get into the secret room in here.
By getting rid of the lanterns.
Yeah, that one showed the trick with the paintings.
Yeah, so there's no point going back into there.
Oh!
Wow!
Okay, I'm surprised I made that.
I don't like the music in here at all.
I'm just like you guys!
That means you should leave me alone!
Hmm...
Oh, wake up.
I can't fly around so much.
So...
I can't drop into the water, probably.
I don't...
Let's see.
Maybe we can see from here.
I don't see any, like, hidden...
Wait, wait, wait.
Wait, just a darn second.
That one over there?
How am I supposed to get there, though?
Hmm.
You think I can jump?
You think I can make it if I jump?
There's no weird parkour needed except for one achievement.
One way to find out.
No, but those scrawny legs Do a double jump Yeah, I don't
have a jetpack How
Do I have to
I don't think if I get it over there I won't be able to jump
up onto the I don't know how to pull myself up You know I am
so sad I I don't know how to use my arms, except we're
holding things, apparently.
Okay.
Maybe.
There's a staircase.
Let's explore a little bit more over here.
Wait, this is where...
Isn't it in there where the guy's walking around?
Or am I crazy?
Let's go the other way then.
If there's someone walking around on the other side, we'll
just go this away then.
Here's an elevator.
I want to get down there, too.
Time to explore just a little bit.
Even though I'm terrified.
I don't like it.
Wait a second!
Can I make it?
Dang it.
Where am I?
Oh.
Oh gosh.
There we go.
Good morning.
Hello.
Okay, we'll have to watch the thing again.
You can't make it.
Sorry, no music this time.
But even if I do make it at that point...
But there's actually a couple seconds before...
Like a little bit before we pass away.
Maybe.
Before the loop consumes us.
Hmm.
Oh, oh, oh, oh.
Which one was it?
No.
S.
Look.
Was it this one?
No.
Where is it?
Uh-oh.
Where's my vision?
It's not this one, right?
No.
Did you say it?
Where is the thing?
Is it on a line?
Or maybe.
Unless it's at the end of this one, is what I'm checking to.
I'm seeing if it...
Okay, it just loops.
Oh, the hidden vault?
Yeah, yeah.
Oh, okay.
Hello.
Points to tower.
Go up the tower.
Hello point artifact.
Back downstairs.
In here.
Snooze.
Wake back up.
Those two turn off.
Then we can enter.
Oh, oops.
My bad.
Oh.
That's what I did though, but...
He doesn't show back up with the artifact.
Like I thought he did.
Ikea directions.
Maybe it's missing something.
Maybe.
Is it okay if I go to the little ghosties room real quick?
You guys just keep watching this.
I'm gonna go to the bathroom and I'm also gonna grab a
little bit of a snack because my tummy is hungry so give me
one second here
I'll be right back I'll be right back give me like five
minutes maybe sorry sorry I'll be right back I'm
back I have pies with me because she was really sad I have
her with me.
Right?
Yeah.
You wanted in here so badly.
You're a banana.
Welcome back.
Thank you.
Okay.
I have a snack.
Butter show you.
Stick potato.
Butter show you stick potato.
I'll have some actual dinner.
afterwards yeah and i have my gamer chopsticks have
we figured anything out you guys said watch it real closely
and um yep
um do i have to stand in like that corner of the room
It's giving me visions.
Mmm, yum, yum, yum, yum, yum.
I'm looking.
What are you doing?
Stop it!
Stop, pies!
Stop.
Stop, don't... Oh my god.
She knocked the...
The top of... Oh my god.
Stop it, you bad girl.
Stop it.
She might get into some stuff, so.
You wanna lay in my chair?
You wanna go plop over there?
Are you gonna plop?
Should plop.
Okay.
I tore off the corner of the bag, and she knocked it off,
and started, like, licking it.
I don't know what to do here.
Oh,
I have to turn off my fishing.
Sorry, my bad.
I have no idea.
I'm stuck.
I'm a little stuck.
I can explore and then come back to the puzzle.
Yeah, but that means I have to go into scary areas again.
I don't know if I want to do that.
And roll.
Perfection.
You cannot avoid the scary.
Are you sure?
Welcome back, boss.
Thank you.
I always am just a little bit off.
Alright, what's a scary area?
Oh, my ship.
Oh, okay, hold on.
I didn't even notice that.
I said that.
Hold on.
Orlando, Idaho.
What are you talking about?
Okay.
Ship log.
Let's see.
Endless Canyon.
Candlelit Lodge is built.
Okay, that was...
I have to remember how to get to these places.
I have to remember how to...
gonna explore the one cave with the ghost matter again.
Oh, yeah.
I can do that place.
Rosado, thanks for two months.
Thank you.
Oh my god, Pis is going kind of crazy.
Starlet cave.
I don't remember which one is which.
I guess we have to explore all three of them.
I guess all of them have something going on.
The light coming out of the vault gave me a vision of a of
climbing a spiral staircase to a room near the top of the
tower.
One of the strangers, it happened, it's pointed at the mural
beneath a ringed planet, then picked up an artifact and
carried it downstairs to a room with a green fire.
Sometime later, two of the lamps in the mural room turned
off, blending the mural into darkness and revealing a secret
passage.
Do I have to like Is it so specific that I have to, like,
put the artifact there and...
I don't know.
The lodge was the place with the hidden canyon?
I haven't been there.
Oh, yes.
Yes.
Yes, we found out the way to get there through the hole.
That's right.
You're right.
I recommend exploring the dark places for more info.
Okay.
We'll just go to the first one then.
We'll just go to the one right here at the very beginning.
I feel like I'm not gonna sleep tonight!
We'll go to this one here.
Damn this whimsy music.
Screw you!
Grab.
Grab and go.
Speed run.
Sending my energy.
Thank you.
I need it.
I'm wobbling it up.
I'm a hungry ghost.
Okay, we'll just go here.
So maybe if they see me, they just wake me up.
Right.
You guys aren't gonna do anything bad to me, right?
Just gonna wake me up.
Bet you wish you touched fish down.
Shut up.
Okay.
We're back in a place.
Is this the DLC version?
It is.
This is Outer Wild's DLC.
It's very scary.
Yeah, there's this door here.
Somebody's house.
Oh yes, this is where this person just gazes.
Into the...
Yep, yep.
Totally normal noise is happening right now.
Everything is pretty normal.
Wake me up.
Wake me up and...
I can't wake up.
Wake me up and save me.
Huh.
Wait, extinguish.
Oh!
Interesting.
What happens if I go there now?
Is the door open?
Oh god.
I'm just a maid.
I'm here to clean your room!
Nothing more, nothing less!
Just a regular maid.
Mid activities.
Of course.
What the hell is that?
Oh.
Hello.
Let's go really quickly.
Oh!
My controller's vibrating.
Wait, isn't that the tower I need to go to?
There are idols yeah they were singing
look i'm a i'm a fan of a big fan of you guys huge fan
that's yeah that's but it's not open good thing we didn't go
down there Why are we going into another cave?
I'm just, I'm just taking it, I'm taking it easy.
Taking it easy.
Oh, I think this is our stop.
I want to see where this goes too.
I'm just seeing where it takes us, you guys.
Life is sometimes about not the destination but the journey.
What's this one?
Wait!
What is this?
I'm intrigued by the staircase.
Oh!
Look, we can even summon a new bow.
It's fine.
A rock.
Oh, the grabby grab.
Okay, I think I gotta get grabbed by this guy.
Woo!
Okay.
This is where they all just sit and stare at what's going on
in here.
Little creepy voyeurs, that's what they are.
What do I, what's, what's my vision?
Okay.
You gotta grab one too?
I did that.
Whoa.
They took it.
Okay.
What's it mean?
So this is where...
Yes, this is where I would...
respawn.
Yes, yes, yes.
Or like, when I go...
When I do this part.
Okay.
Yeah, they were carrying something.
I took it downstairs.
It's interesting though because when I leave this, I am not
in this place.
Speedifier!
Thanks for the vibe, gifted!
Thank you!
Huh.
Oh yes, I went underground, right?
I went, it was like the subterranean, no that's not the
lake.
That's not the subterranean lake.
Is it?
Can I see it though?
Faster.
Maybe we can go to that one platform I missed.
I'm scared.
This is...
A place!
Is this where...
We started?
I think so.
Yeah.
Yeah, this is where we started.
I'm not gonna stop.
And we'll hear them singing again.
I think.
Doing their weird culty, whatever.
Weird culty, whatever going on in there.
Tiger, fire, cyber, fire.
Wait, did it mean to...
Wait.
Did it yell before?
I can't remember.
Ha.
Did it...
Did it yell before?
Did it do that scream before?
Ha.
Huh.
Maybe let's find a boat.
There's one down there.
Or maybe it saw me, and that's why I yelled.
I spooked it, maybe.
A boat.
Any boats around?
I feel like we were in there for such a long time.
Before...
before the dam broke.
Ah, an alien!
Says the alien.
No, they say, ah, ghost!
I'm just waiting for this boat to come on by.
A boat?
Where the hell did it go?
Is it stuck?
Maybe this helps push it.
Hello!
This is so, like...
Oh my god, there's the boat!
Are you kidding me?
It's upside down!
Oh, this is fine.
We'll just ride this.
Here we go.
There we go.
Even better.
This reminds me of when I took the, you know, the river...
The river sticks.
Sanzu no Kawa.
Good times.
Okay, nice.
And...
Nice.
Time to go back into the creepy world.
But I liked being on the boat.
I felt pretty safe there.
gonna lie I didn't mind so much being on the boat oops I
always go the wrong direction I kind of liked it I kind of
felt safe and like it was kind of chill you know anyways
guys see you never I hope see you never I hope oh but
this area has the guy walking around, doesn't it?
Yeah, I think this is the area where he's walking around
upstairs.
Where's the boat at?
Where's the boat?
Okay, there was some guy walking up there.
Someone walking up here, too.
Pretty sure.
Will he see me if I walk out here?
There's No windows, maybe not.
I can get grabby-grabbed.
Or what's down here?
Ah!
Oh, God.
Oh!
I didn't mean to get grabby-grabbed.
It really scared me.
Oh, my God.
Wait, am I on the second floor now?
Am I on their level?
Oh.
But if I grabby grab over there, I will not be grabby
grabbing back because there's nothing here.
Let's go back to the other side.
Guys, this is too spooky for me.
Whew.
Okay.
I wanted to go...
Oh, wait.
I have to drop down.
If I drop down, will I...
Wait.
Oh, here we go.
I was going to say, will I be okay?
I can't...
Wee-woo, wee-woo, wee-woo, wee-woo.
Well, that, now we know.
Maybe, um, I have to go through there without any light.
I think.
She caught out without dying.
Stop, you guys are making me so scared.
I'm really
scared.
so scared
well let's just drop some
you progress five meters each loop that doesn't seem very
much I'm not really finding anything in the other world I
mean I'm trying I am looking around but I am not finding so
much oh whoops that's totally not even related.
Hmm.
You're close, you just need to figure something.
Okay.
Figuring out one thing at a time does help.
You found the boat, last loop, in the area with the bell,
this one.
True.
How did I get to the boat?
Oh, wait.
No, I remember.
That was just the normal path that we took.
Let's just go back there.
The boat kind of leads us to everywhere, so it seems pretty
nice, actually.
And I know you guys are trying to scare me.
They're like, you guys are like, she doesn't know about the
boat.
She doesn't know.
Well.
Um.
Whatever.
She doesn't know.
She doesn't know the boat.
But we can go.
back to the bell or rather wait we're trying to figure out
the bell on on uh from the outside right or oh oh my
goodness forgetting how to play i'm forgetting how to drive
matching velocity and doing a roll
perfect don't forget my suit
All right,
let's...
I'm getting kind of good at speedrunning this, I think.
I'm getting a little good at it.
And I've always been good at driving this boat.
Okay, let's grab our artifact.
Hooray!
And let's...
Oh!
Whoopsie!
Let's...
Let's fly up, let's grab our artifact, and drop.
Okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay, okay,
okay, okay, okay,
okay, okay, okay, okay.
This is the boat.
Actually, hold on.
Never mind.
I was gonna say, does the picture, like, represent where I'm
going, but I don't think so.
Oh, it's not dark enough.
There we go.
I should have eaten it.
I should have had it anyway.
Good morning.
Nobody.
Good boy.
I mean, oh boy.
I am not trying to call the alien.
He is a good boy.
That was a mistake.
Um, oof.
Um, meow.
I wish they would pre-put that line back into...
Sonic.
Uh, meow.
Alright, come on, boat!
What is that?
There's...
Someone over there.
Or was that my...
That wasn't my cursor, was it?
Wait.
Was that...
Was that the little dot in the middle?
Or was that...
Wait.
Was that...
Was that the...
It was something.
right there it is yeah it's not my dot at all it is it is it
was walking it was walking I saw it
it wasn't me going crazy so there is something walking
around in here oh no no no no no no no no no no no no oh
golly Taking it slow.
Anywhere to get off?
Or...
No?
No where...
My controller just vibrated.
Nowhere to get off?
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
Act like you belong.
Yeah.
Oh, this one!
This one I wanted to get off on before too.
Let's see what happens here.
I think just another...
I think this will call it probably just another boat, right?
But...
Wait!
There's also an elevator here.
Hi!
Just calls another boat.
That's what I figured.
So, basically, we will come down from up there at some
point.
Miss Prizzle, I don't like this field trip.
Ah!
This game is so scary.
It's so dark.
And I even turned the brightness up.
So here, this secret, they carried that thing down.
There's no one here though, right?
Right?
Yeah.
There's no one here though, right?
I think.
This calls another boat, right?
Yeah, okay.
Hmm.
go into non-existence.
I like that.
Yeah, I noticed that earlier too.
It's just kind of, you know, by the power of God and anime
holding up this.
What if I shine it on your planet, huh?
Really bright, huh?
You don't like that, huh?
So this is where we teleport into.
And this is the visions.
they kidnap they they they de-thorax Matara essentially
hold on while this is going on I'm gonna check on pies
she has wrapped herself in a blanket she has wrapped herself
in a blanket she seems Okay, she seems like she's doing all
right.
Let's see.
There's like a parkour, maybe.
I'm not sure there's anything even down here, though.
Oh!
Maybe here.
Parkour.
Oh!
Oh, we're fine.
Uh.
Yeah.
Dang it.
Give you one second.
Um...
Oh, shoot.
I feel like I'm gonna be trapped here for a while.
I feel like I might have to cook this, cook on this a little
bit.
I might have to...
think about this a little bit.
I did say I wanted only today's stream to be only three
hours but I feel like I mean we learned a lot but also I
feel like I'm just like
you've got everything in dream four now try dream two three
or one wait this is four two three or one
there's that one and was there one over here There's this
house right here That we have to enter through the other way
And, uh Don't think there was anyone here either
There it goes Destroying everything Oh, am I in trouble?
Uh No, we're okay That was so giddy-giddy.
That was really close, actually.
We're all right.
Giddy-giddy safe.
Hmm.
I'm going to try.
Well, that part's all going to be destroyed in just a
second, isn't it?
We're going to watch it all get...
Yep, there it goes.
There it goes!
But I think we could still go in there.
So there's a couple things that we need to figure out.
One is the the Ghost Matter Cave.
What's the matter?
What's the ghost matter cave?
Oh my gosh.
Have you guys heard of...
Have you heard of the Matter Baby?
What's the matter, Baby?
I don't know, what's the matter with you?
The matter, baby!
What's the matter, baby?
The ghost matter, baby.
This way, this way, this way!
Push, push, push!
Nice, nice, nice.
Oh!
Oh, whoa!
Artifact, you okay?
Yep.
All good.
Uh...
Anyway.
I actually can't remember which way it was.
I think it's that one up there, maybe?
No.
That's a projector room.
Up here, maybe?
I think we can't get up there.
No, wait, that's, uh...
Is there no sleepy guys in this area?
Sleepy...
Dear bird people in your area!
You can jump the bridge for sure from the top, but can't we
get to the top?
The real question...
I think I thought I was going somewhere, but I...
Went the wrong... I... I... I... Oh, wait!
This is the ca- This is the... This is a cave.
What was in here again?
Oh, gosh.
Okay, I feel like I need to start taking notes or something.
It's a little overwhelming.
It's a lot of information.
Oh, it's up there!
There!
There it is.
Okay, okay, okay.
If we can get to the top.
Oh, wait.
This way, this way, this way.
Come on, come on, come on, come on.
I don't know if I can make that.
No!
The river's too strong.
You know what, since we're here, let's go to the bell.
Oh my god, I thought that was a dancing egg again.
I thought there was an egg on my screen.
What are you up to currently?
I don't know.
I've never played this game.
Or this DLC before.
I have no idea what I'm up to, what I'm down to.
Down to clown.
That's what I'm always down to.
Oh, he's down to clown, baby.
Good morning.
Then they took it downstairs.
I don't see any doors or anything around here, though.
We must also go downstairs.
We can't go through there.
We have to...
What is that?
We have to seal that up somehow.
I imagine.
Hmm.
Unless do we...
Oh.
Does it, like, seal up when...
When, like, the things fall or whatever, I wonder.
I'm gonna seal it up with, uh...
Gosh, what's that stuff?
That guy, like, slams it on the ground.
on the, on the, not flex tape.
Maybe it is flex tape.
Oh, it is flex tape.
Yeah, we're gonna, wow, with the flex tape.
Plants.
It's really peaceful over here.
There's also a boat.
I wonder if I have to wait for, like,
hmm?
Oh.
Did they scream when the tower falls?
Interesting.
But nothing covers it up.
Oh!
Goodness gracious.
Oh, I'm sorry.
Have you ever heard of Good Dog?
What's that?
Can I conceal it and go into the water.
Actually, let's try it since we're about to die anyway.
Nope.
I guess we're the shot.
Oh, what's good, dog?
What's good, dog?
You're cooking, though, and then case i'm trying i'm trying
i'm trying i think i'm gonna have to cook i think i'm gonna
have to let this one sit in my brain for until next time i
think
marinate we'll continue next week we'll finish it next week
Hmm, you're close.
I don't even know what I'm close to, though.
You're missing very important piece of the plot to figure
stuff out.
So I am still missing something.
I mean, I figured.
But...
One place we also need to go back to is that one place that
had the guy watching TV...
Yeah.
Close to like five things.
I don't even know what I'm close to.
I wish... I miss when my biggest mystery was what was firing
out of that cannon.
I wish when that... I wish... I miss...
I wish... I miss when that was the biggest mystery.
but I'll go through some of this stuff and figure it out or
try to figure out I will cook until until I can cook no
longer until it is burnt fried
unrecognizable the arrows give you info yeah projection
reveals a cave entrance at the base of a rocky island with a
tall tower yeah i went there i saw that i totally did that i
can't figure out this dang tower you you stinking tower the
hidden vault seals oh why can't they just show me the code
they wrote their password on the wall why can't they show me
also the password in their projection as well in the visions
huh why can't they show me there too you're making plenty of
progress just keep going I will I will next week yeah
it's really fantastic watching you play through this game
your enthusiasm and energy are top tier you'll figure it out
soon thank you ah I want to keep going but I do need to get
some good sleep tonight so that's what I will be doing I
will be cutting it off here I even went a little bit than
what I was planning on.
Oh, how naive I was to think that I would solve this in two
streams.
Oh, that's okay.
It is what it is.
I also have some work that I have to do.
So I'm going to go do that before I go to sleep.
Thank you guys for joining me again today.
I hope you guys, your brains are hurting as much as mine is.
a crazy amount um it was very interesting to um go into the
spooky world and finally get the spookiness of the dlc
thanks for streaming it always makes me smile thank you have
a good rest and well soon thank you thank you thank you
Chill.
Tomorrow is fun.
No brain-herdy game of deal or no deal.
So, Otzumito, everybody.
Thank you.
I would stick around more.
Luckily, this tea is helping my throat a whole lot.
But, um, I'm gonna go rest my voice now.
Um, I had double streams today's too, so.
Hmm.
It's been a busy day.
Otzumito.
Have a good night, everybody.
Thank you for helping me out.
We'll solve more mysteries next time.
Bye, bye, bye, bye, wait.
Okay, pause is still in the blanket.
Bye-bye, bye-bye, bye-bye.